Hello, everyone on the
internet watching this video,
how are you?
I'm fine, thanks for asking.
How are you, Dan?
Yeah, great.
What we've got for you today.
So I'll just do it all, Dan.
Oh yeah.
So what are we doing here today
on this village base then?
Well, what happened is,
this happens quite a lot I've discovered.
Video games come out, right.
And obviously from my hoodie,
you'll know that I'm a massive video fan.
I am an achievement
Hunter in my spare time.
I play games too.
He plays games, he
doesn't get paid for it.
It's slightly different.
So EA has brought us here
to blow stuff up basically.
Yeah. we're an old military base
and we're going to reenact
some stuff from Battlefield 4
Let's run the clip.
Yeah, here we go.
Grenade.
Yeah. So you might be thinking,
well I wouldn't trust The
Slomo Guys with a grenade,
but they somehow have--
Who gave me this, who
trusts me with this?!?
I certainly don't, give me that.
I shouldn't be-
You should not be holding that,
I was scared for my life there.
So basically all we're going to do,
even though the wind is picking up,
we're going to blow up a lot of stuff,
we're going to just throw a
grenade on the floor and then
we're going to blow up something with it.
So if you're okay with
that, we'll commence.
All right. So we're at the wind.
You are obviously a specialist
in explosives in the British
Army.
What do you know about FI grenades?
Okay.
I've got a demo.
H G FI grenade.
It's got two, two safeties here.
We've got the safety pin.
First thing you do is you
pull the safety pin out.
Then you've got a fly flavor
here. That's spring loaded.
And you hold that in with
your hand. Like, so, okay.
So the first thing you can
do pull the safety pin out.
Then this is spring loaded.
Like I mentioned before,
you're gonna throw the grenade
that then asserts itself.
And the spring round, there's a striker,
which comes around with the fluff lever.
Okay. And that impacts on the fuse.
The fuse itself has to delay
competition within it. Okay.
And that lasts between three
and a half and four and a half
seconds.
Burns down into the main
fill of the grenade,
which is 155 grams of RDX and
TNT and a ratio of about 54 to
46%.
Right. So delay competition burns down,
initiates the main field,
which detonates at about
6,000 meters a second.
Right. Then on the inside,
you've got a steel coil
wrapped around the inside,
around the part of the
outside of the grenade.
Right. That's got notches in
it and that provides pre formed
fragmentation. So the grenade itself.
So throw it, initiates.
And then that's what kills people.
Okay.
Is this the second time you've been smart
in a Slomo Guys video?
Yeah. It is, yeah.
That's two in like five videos.
You're really wreaking things up.
So we're going to have the grenade there
and Dan and I will
be safe behind this little blast shield.
And we're filming with a fence of flex.
Very fast. Isn't it?
Yeah.
They look good. It was pretty cool.
What are you gonna do next?
I reckon we should do one
in a puddle, actually.
Thankfully, we've got plenty of puddles.
Well, we took care of that pesky puddle,
but one thing we haven't shown is the
destructible environments and stuff.
Battlefields and all that.
We should blow something
up that is destructible.
Whoa, wait, wait, I'm
going to stop you there.
We not going to blow up
anyone house up again.
That is not happening.
That is a shame because that's
exactly what I was thinking
Oh !
How about instead of that then,
just scout the area and
we'll see if we can find
just a randomly, conveniently stacked
bunch of explosive barrels.
video game style.
What are the chances of that?
Probably really high.
is going to have wonderful, fun.
Wonder if we'll find
exactly what we wanted.
What are the chances of that?
I can't believe it.
Ready?
That was absolutely massive!
I missed it.
Stay away from the camera.
I actually missed it.
It's complete white out.
Geez...
Look at that.
I didn't get to see the damages.
I was running away.
Jumping away.
How was your dive?
Yeah, it was good.
The thing is, it was natural.
'Cause I was like: holy crap.
Oh my god.
Look at all the crap here.
It even knocked over one
of the concrete things--
It blew up the pillar.
Look, the concrete thing got blown up.
The doors seemed to
make it intact actually.
Still smoldering that.
Oh yeah.
Careful.
Look at that.
I love how we went from blowing up nothing
to blowing up a puddle
To an entire building.
Viscerally.
Good work.
I want to do it again?
You want to do it again?
Your parent's house?
I'm good to go,
let's do it.